Hello, everybody!
Sorry, I'm like a little dead inside.
Alright, um, alright.
Little life update.
A little life update.
Sorry, I fucking...
I'm not tired because like, um, since like, you know, dad always wakes me up at a reasonable, quote unquote, reasonable time every morning.
Uh, cause you know, he needs to eat and... he needs to eat and have a walkies.
Um, anyway, uh, yesterday... did I sleep?
Uh...
Um, you know, I thought that like, yesterday... yesterday, I thought that like, you know, um...
You know, that everything will be okay.
And that like, I beat the addiction.
And that like, you know, um, things will be okay.
And then I got a message from a friend who was like, You wanna play some Overwatch?
I was ready to get some work done.
And I was ready, um, I was like locked in and ready to do it.
And then I got the message.
You wanna play some Overwatch?
Yeah.
And then I'm back every time.
I... Every time...
Doki don't you have a say, don't you have a Street Fighter tournament?
Should you?
Sh...
That's what my friend said.
Like, one of my friends was like, Why are you always complaining about... like...
You're always complaining about how all the players in the beginning division is grinding so much and then you're out here playing Overwatch instead of practicing for City Champs.
This is not what matters right now.
Look, I don't have a coach yet.
So like...
I don't have a coach yet.
What's the point of learning right now if like, you know...
I don't know what I'm doing.
Anyway...
So then I went to bed at 6 in the morning today.
It just takes...
It only takes one message.
Chat.
And then I'm back in it.
I would be like...
Oh my god.
It's so...
I've been so good to myself.
I haven't...
I haven't played Overwatch in a couple of days.
I've been so good at this.
And then all it takes is one message.
What?
Do you want to play Overwatch?
And then...
And then I...
I blink...
I close my eyes.
And I open my eyes.
And it's 6 in the morning.
It's like you're trapped in this Overwatch trance.
Like time just passes by so fast.
And then you're just like...
What happened?
I thought it was still 10pm.
When did the sun come out?
Yes, I've been in Bastards for like a week now.
Anyway...
I'll be okay for today.
As long as nobody sends me a message.
I will not relapse.
I will not relapse back into it.
Um...
Look.
It's not...
It's not just me.
It's my surroundings.
It's not...
It's not just my fuzz.
It's my...
It's my surroundings.
I don't know.
I have the willpower to not solo queue anymore, um, for now, but, but like, whenever somebody messages me, then, then I just, I, I close my eyes, and then it's 6am.
Yeah, anyway, anyway, so, you know what's funny?
I thought it was so funny that, like, uh, tweeting out I'm a Honda main, um, reveals how so many people, um, revealed how so many people did not watch the Street Fighter stream yesterday.
I was like, I was like, it exposed all of you, it worked, but it worked!
I told you guys, I, I make everyone think I'm a Honda main, so everybody's gonna train, like, everybody's, except for Goomy, everybody's gonna train just exclusively, um, for Honda, and then, I love how someone's like, I'm a Toyota main, that was, that was pretty good.
That's the only reason why I tweeted it out, uh, it's just, I was like, I wanted to confuse everybody, so, like, everybody will think I literally made a Honda, and then everybody's gonna be training for it, and nobody will expect when I pull out my real main,
Akuma.
I, the Twitter mix-up, exactly, um, it's, it's the mix-up that no one's ever prepared for.
Uh, I flipped the script.
Yeah, I flipped it.
I just thought it was so funny, like, so many people actually, actually think that I'm maining, maining him.
Um, hi, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Please take care of yourself, young lady.
It only takes one hit.
One message, and I'm back, I'm back at it again.
No!
One of my friends actually DMed me saying, Overwatch, alright, guys, I'm gonna change the stream, we're gonna play some Overwatch.
No, I'm joking, I'm joking, it's monkey day, it's, it's monkey week, guys.
I hope you guys are not tired of monkey, I know, like, everybody and their fucking moms and dads and, like, unborn children are playing Wukong now.
Um, and, like, I found out this game is actually 30 to 40 hours long.
Um.
Which is, which is a lot longer than I thought.
When they said it, I was like, oh, six chapters, that can't be that bad, I mean, six is not, I mean, Dead Space has, like, 12 plus chapters, and that's not 20 to, that's not, like, 30 hours long, oh, my gosh.
Um.
30 of you skip, yes, 30 of you skip optional content, too, and I think I've done, like, every single, like, boss, like, even the optional bosses, too.
Um, and I, like, I don't mind doing the optional bosses, because it just levels me up, and, like, it just helps me in the long run, in the, in the long run for, like, um, for the, like, mandatory late stage bosses.
Anyway, uh, please let me know if there's stutters or anything, because, like, uh, I actually, um, remember when, like, uh, yesterday, not yesterday, last Wukong stream, people were like, oh, man, you're, you're stuttering and stuff.
And it has, like, a lot of stutters.
And it has, like, and then you guys gaslighted me into thinking it was YouTube.
It was not YouTube.
It was actually on my end.
It was actually on his.
It was actually me, guys.
And I was like, oh, my God, thank God.
Everyone on last stream, I was like, oh, man, I feel like it's me, guys.
They're like, no, it's YouTube.
And it's like, oh, okay.
Okay.
And I was like, I always think it's my fault, because, like, I'm cursed with forever.
I knew I was the problem.
I knew it.
Deep down, when you guys were like...
Oh, it's YouTube.
Deep down, I knew it was me.
I knew it was me.
I was like, maybe it's me.
There's always me.
It's always...
So, the mods and I, the mods and I, we were, like, messing about with, like, the settings and everything.
We sort of fixed our CPU issue.
So, every time, like, last Wukong stream, we went to 100% CPU.
And I think, I don't know, guys, it could be that.
Like, I don't think I should have been at 100% CPU when I was streaming Wukong.
But I don't remember what we did.
Oh, yeah, we...
I had one of my tech friends also help me.
And they did TeamViewer and, like, helped me, like, I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck he did.
Like, he's in, like...
Text...
Support.
So, like, I don't know what he did.
But he was, like...
I was, like, watching him just do stuff on my PC.
Like, turning settings off.
By the way, I wasn't on admin mode, by the way, for OBS.
Because, like, I was lazy.
And so...
Because, like, I know there was a way to make it so that you can boot up OBS in admin mode, like, automatically.
Like, just clicking it instead of, like, right-click at...
Sorry, in admin mode.
But I was, like, I was a bit lazy in, like, you know, just a little bit.
And, like, trying to figure out how to do that.
So, my friend made sure that everything I boot up now will be in admin mode.
So, like, that's also a good thing.
So, now my CPU is at 52% instead of, you know, 100%.
But if there are any stutters, please let me know.
So, then, like, then we know that I didn't fix the problem.
And...
Then we know that I didn't fix the problem.
So, yes, I'm taking my friend's credit.
Then, did you two just...
No, don't gaslight me.
Don't fucking gaslight me.
Anyway, then we know that, like, we didn't fix the problem.
Then I know that my friend didn't fix the problem.
Yes, now that there's a problem, I'm blaming him instead of me.
Because I take credit.
I take credit when good stuff happens.
And then I blame others when bad stuff happens.
Because that is the life of a streamer.
We have...
It's never our fault.
Anyway.
As I was saying, I start...
Don't say that!
Don't fucking say...
I start saying...
Come on.
Because now I don't know.
Now I don't know if you're saying that to fuck with me.
Or if it's actually true.
Like, the game isn't even on.
Like, it started for real.
For real.
Fuck you guys.
Anyway.
Because now I won't know until the stream is over.
If it actually is stuttering.
Okay, where was I?
Fuck.
Now I lost my train of thought.
Because I got angry.
Anyway.
Oh, fuck.
What was my train of thought?
Don't worry for the stutter.
I have ADHD.
Kara, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Hi, Toki.
It's my birthday today.
And my family is six that are isolating right now.
Thank you for streaming.
Making my day a little better.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Liam.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
Anyway, I'm glad you're enjoying the stream.
Even though you're just looking at a black screen right now.
Fuck, where was I?
Okay, where was I before Wukong?
I don't even know what I was talking about before Wukong.
Um, this is the streamer brain rot at this point.
Uh, but yes, anyway, so like, please let me know if there's actual real fucking stutters, um, and, and not trying to, I, I would really appreciate it if you guys don't gaslight me, but yes, we believe we might have fixed the issue.
So, uh, so we'll see on this Wukong stream.
I'm sorry for, I know a lot of people were like, where's god of war?
Um, the reason why we're focusing on Wukong instead of god of war is that, um, it's because, uh, I've been very addicted to monkeys.
So, and like, uh, I don't like playing two story games at the same time because, uh, I would, like, lose track of the story.
Uh, I would lose track of the story and then, like, I would forget the controls, uh, because I have, there's just too many stuff going on.
Um, back to back to back.
So, that's why I'm focusing on Wukong and then we'll do, and then we'll do the cooler god.
Don't say that because you'll actually piss off the god of war, uh, fans.
They'll get very mad.
Anyway, that's the hill you die on.
That's not me.
I, I am just a bystander.
I just, they're all good.
Games.
I, I, uh, the one, one of one, so I, I do get into video game arguments, but, like, I know when to, like, I know when to, like, you know, back off.
Because, like, there are some video game arguments you don't get involved in.
Like, I could be, like, yeah, like, I, I would say that I think Deadlock is not fun.
But, cause, cause, like, it's League.
It's, like, I got tricked.
Cause, like, it's fucking League.
Um, but, like, that's something I can say.
Because, it's, like, it, cause some people, like, were, like, yeah, like, as someone who doesn't like League.
Yeah, you're right.
If you like League, then you'll like it.
But, like, I fucking hate League.
And I can say I hate League.
Because, um, even League players hate League.
So, like, that's fine to say.
But, like, hey, there are some video game arguments, uh, that you should not get involved in.
It's dope.
Okay, it's dope.
And not League.
To me, they're all the same.
I'm sorry.
To me, League and Dota, you watch your mouth, Toki.
League and Dota, to me, are just the same to me.
Take that back!
They're different!
You're right.
League is actually popular.
I know!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha...
Okay.
Holy... take... that... back!
Uh... JL, thank you for the... Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Toki.
I was born under the Steel Monkey.
So I send you my Steel Monkey Energy!
May it boost you in Wukong!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Alright.
So, yes, I'm willing to attack.
Like...
Like I said, there are some video game arguments that I'm willing to get involved in, and there are some I'm not.
I like how I decided to piss off League and Dota players.
So like, you know, with League, that would be like, you know, 90% of my chat, and then like the 1% of Dota players.
That's fucked up.
Alright.
Beep boop, Jesus, because he was right.
Yeah, yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, anyway, I'm looking forward to play some more Wukong, some more Monkey.
Quantum, thank you for the five gift issues.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Oh, so yes, I walked...
I was actually very surprised today that...
Because like, he didn't poop yesterday.
For Dad, DirtyAmberDoge.
He didn't poop yesterday because like, for like late...
Not like all the whole day yesterday, but like for his like second walk, like his nighttime walks.
Because there was a...
Because he hates the rain.
So like, there was like a...
There was like a rainstorm.
And I even gave him like a little ring.
And I gave him like a little raincoat to wear.
But like, you...
This is why I'm so...
This is why like, I don't know what to do with him when it's raining.
Like, I don't know.
Because he doesn't want to...
He doesn't...
He's like holding it in.
And he holds it in.
And he was like...
He was like, oh man.
Maybe it'll not rain tomorrow.
But like, I can't take that gamble.
I...
I was like...
I can't take that gamble of you...
Like...
Thinking tomorrow will be a better day.
So...
So I'm like, we're both miserable.
I know you want to go home.
I'm miserable that we're walking in the rain.
You're miserable that you're walking in the rain.
But we have to do this.
Because he kept like...
He kept like...
He peed and then he just wants to go back.
He doesn't care.
And then...
And I'm like, no.
We still have to do this.
Like...
Anyway...
He won yesterday.
So...
Because like today, luckily, the rain stopped.
So like...
He took the gamble.
He took the 50-50 gacha that the rain will stop by tomorrow.
And it did.
So like...
Good for him.
But then...
Okay, when I was walking...
He's such a little shit sometimes.
When I was walking back...
I don't know why.
Somebody left like two pizza crusts on the floor.
Like on the sidewalk.
I didn't know.
Because like usually it's clean.
Usually it's fucking clean.
Um...
So then like...
I was just walking.
And then he's...
And then suddenly he like...
Walked up to like...
A place.
He's like...
And I was like...
What the fuck?
I was like...
What?
No!
Donkey, no!
And then he like spit it out.
But I was just like...
What the fuck?
And then he just...
Casually walked over.
So I didn't like...
Expect it at all.
He like...
Casually like...
Walked over.
Because like...
You know...
If there's food...
Like normal...
Normal dogs.
They would like...
You know...
Rush over and eat it.
He...
Fucking just...
Casually walked over.
So I had no suspicion at all.
That there's food on the floor.
Because I was like...
I was...
I was so tired.
So I was not...
Mentally there.
Like...
I was not mentally there.
I was just autopiloting the walk.
Because he already pooped and peed.
So like...
We're just walking back home.
So he played it cool.
And...
Yeah.
He knows that if he rushes...
I will stop him.
So I was just like...
It's just the walk back home.
And we're literally like...
Like...
30 steps almost back.
We're like 30...
Like 20 to 30 steps...
Almost back.
Almost back home.
And he's just...
And I saw...
I was like...
You know...
That sudden movement freaked me out.
Because I was like...
What the fuck?
I was like...
I saw a giant pizza crust in his mouth.
And I was like...
Donkey, no!
And he just spits it out.
Because he knows.
He's like...
Oh shit.
She saw...
He saw...
She saw me.
And then we continued the walk.
I was like...
Thank God.
Thank God he spit it out.
Because I was like...
Oh my God.
What the fuck do I do?
I don't want to...
So yeah.
He was...
He was definitely a little shit today.
And yesterday as well.
He was...
He was like...
I don't know where he gets it from.
I don't...
Clearly not me.
Because I'm so well behaved.
I'm actually getting outplayed by a dog.
Weeding dogs are surprisingly very smart for how tiny they are.
They're actually really fucking smart.
I'm not kidding.
They're way too smart for their own good.
They're way too smart for their own good though.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
All right.
Now we actually play the video game.
Now after the entire life update, we can finally play the video game.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's get that out here.
Oh yeah.
What's this?
I need to look up what the sound is that put Wukong in.
Okay.
10.8.
5.
And then Street Fighter is...
I always screenshot the sound and everything so that I would know...
So if I'm playing the game again, I will know to put it back at the same volume.
So I don't have to always be like, sound guy, what's the volume?
And everything.
We're finally...
Don't...
Don't fuck with me.
I know there was no stutter.
Don't fuck...
Because the stutter only happens visually, not like on stream, like not, not like the voice and everything.
So like, I don't even have the game up yet, guys.
So I know you're fucking with me.
I fucking know you're messing with me just because the game hasn't even been up yet.
When you said it was...
Also.
Yeah.
Like, um, um, I traveled around a little bit, uh, played a little game a little bit because, um, uh, because, uh, we had to test out the game and everything.
So, uh, yeah.
Yeah.
You guys are gonna do like the Dragoon who cried wolf.
The Dragoon who cried stutters, like, and then nobody will be happy.
This affects all of us.
This affects your stream experience if you cried stutters.
Sorry, I had to hide it.
All right.
So yeah, I accidentally went into a place that I should not have went to because I didn't know there was going to be a cut scene.
I didn't know it was a new location.
I wanted to see if I could find like an optional boss, but there was no optional bosses to find.
So I accidentally.
Explored an area.
That I should not have explored.
I had to come clean with it.
I had to.
I made a mistake there.
All right.
Play through.
It's not.
It's just one area.
It's literally one area.
Like it doesn't make that much of a difference, guys.
It was one area.
Let me make sure the.
Because I also updated my graphics driver.
And I hate it when you update your graphics driver.
Like things.
Things go like.
I was so worried.
Like everything resets.
And stuff.
Now.
It was just.
Three cinematic shots.
Of like a location.
That was it.
If I didn't tell you, you guys would not have known.
Because.
But because.
That was it.
Because.
I am such a kind.
Oh, she.
And kind.
And transparent.
Oh, she.
I was willing to admit.
That I.
I.
Explored a little bit too much.
Like.
Three.
That's way too many.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
And I.
Farmed a little bit of will.
Because I know I need.
Like four million willpower.
Or some shit.
All right.
Was it the village?
It was some fucking.
It was some.
It was like.
This.
Uh.
Temple.
Like a temple.
Uh.
So.
Like.
I don't know.
It was like.
It was that other area.
Where like.
Uh.
I had to go past the bridge.
Or.
Uh.
I had to go past the bridge.
Or.
Not.
And I chose.
And then you guys told me to not go to the bridge.
That was basically.
Yes.
I know we stuttered there.
Like.
I could see the frame drop there.
But.
That's not.
That.
That's just on the game.
Like.
Don't.
Don't say that.
Oh.
There's a.
Yes.
I saw the frame.
Guys.
We all saw the frame drop.
We all.
All right.
Let's see.
I'm so lost.
Will I ever figure out where to go?
Stream experience.
It's not at 100% CPU.
Guys.
Now.
I actually don't know.
Whenever.
You're at.
Like.
Where to go.
Do I have mods?
Like.
I'm at the point where.
I can't trust anything.
I assume I can trust the mods.
Right?
Like.
Do I have mods on right now?
The CPU is upset.
I am.
I'm literally monitoring my CPU right now.
I am literally monitoring my CPU.
Holy shit.
Dude.
They're not even worth.
They're not even worth killing it gives me 67 Whirl.
I am a money or not.
Let's go.
Wow, what happened to your check mark?
Let me give you... what happened to your wrench?
Let me give you a wrench right now.
Wow.
You got me.
You sure fooled me.
You can trust me.
That is like a bullshit lie told by fucking grandpas who actually can't see more than 24 frames.
Iridescent, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We know the human eye cannot see more than... it's 30 frames though.
Oh, this guy was born in 1900s.
In 1930s, it was... it got into 30 frames.
And it never went up from there.
You can't even trust the mods.
Where do I go?
It's just a turtle.
Where the fuck...
Look, if we like can only see...
Only see it at like 30 frames or whatever.
Then like...
Why the fuck do we keep making like higher hertz monitors?
Like that's...
It's a conspiracy.
Oh, there he is.
Chewbacca.
Why are you so short?
Leave.
To sell us newer monitors.
It was a conspiracy from the tech bros.
They fooled us all by saying we can actually see in higher FPS.
So that they'll...
So that we'll keep buying more monitors.
That will be a total...
It's a conspiracy from Big Display.
That's why it's called the Illuminati.
Illuminate?
Oh, coincidence.
What the...
Whoa...
Oh...
Yeah, stop crying.
Don't be a little bitch.
You're just a giant turtle.
Quit fucking crying.
Oh, wait.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Light the incense.
I still can't believe they haven't even... they haven't fixed the subtitles thing.
The accessibility on the subtitles.
It's been so long.
I would think they would hotfix because that's literally my only complaint.
Out of everything about this game, my only complaint is subtitles too tiny.
The turtle was a Dota player.
That's why he was crying.
Let's see.
Oh shit, what?
Pig, do the thing.
Oh, what the fuck did he throw up?
That's fucked.
Okay, that's also fucked.
What are you throwing?
What did you eat?
You're too tiny.
Are you bulimic?
Oh my god, please love yourself.
Oh hey, it's that guy again.
His tumor head.
Alright, this guy willing to use magic.
He's actually really frustrating to fight against.
Big baby.
Doki hates Dota confirmed.
I don't hate it.
I just don't care.
What's worse than hate?
Like, what's it called?
What's the word for like not caring?
That's what's worse.
Ambulance or whatever.
It's not my fault you're tiny.
You're tiny.
Tiny legs.
Apathy, yeah.
Indifference, yeah.
The worst... the thing worse than hate is just indifference.
Wait, another incense already?
Where the fuck am I?
Is there another... I literally just got here.
Alright, I guess... I guess I like the incense.
Oh, go back and go up or down.
Okay, I like how you're like...
By the way, it could be up.
It could be down.
But like, there's a boss there.
That... thank you.
That really helped when it came the direction.
Okay.
I accidentally pressed R.
Was it an advice or a riddle?
Let's find out.
How did I miss this?
It was literally right in front of me.
Alright, it's either up or down.
At least it's not left or right.
If you add it in any more directions, I definitely will get lost.
Alright, let's see.
Travel, new west...
There you go.
I'm just too lazy to... to figure this out.
I don't want to travel.
I don't want to walk back.
Why walk back when I can like... fast pass?
Alright.
Up.
Okay, it's either down or it's either up.
So we'll go down first.
How much does he give?
I want to know.
How much willpower?
Okay, 86 is not...
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, I literally just wasted a little bit of my HP for the boss fight.
Do I get XP if...
If Pigsy kills him?
I do.
Okay, that's good.
Alright, that's the beach, right?
Is that the beach?
Is that the one with the dinos?
Oh, is that another dragon that fostered over there?
Oh, is that him?
Are you bad?
He looks bad.
Oh no, he's not.
He's just a regular guy.
He's just...
He's like, I was just enjoying the scenery.
And I came in with a giant baby.
He's just a dude.
He's just like, oh man, I can't wait to go on my regular...
On my regular beach walk.
And then...
And then I came over there and shanked him like I was in London.
Like the shank drive-by.
I was like, no walks for you.
You're trying to enjoy your day?
How dare you?
This is Wukong territory.
I mean, I am a little shit.
I am...
Alright, let's see.
Wait, it disappeared.
Did I already got it?
I must have already got it somehow.
Oi, mate.
I'm trying to enjoy lovely...
Fucking English.
You're trying to enjoy lovely school on beach, eh?
No walks for you.
Okay.
Oh no, I don't have the thing.
I stuttered IRL.
I had an IRL stutter.
Where the fuck is this boss?
The Wukong clan is here.
I mean, he did have one.
They just all died.
Apparently, the fucking gods killed most of them.
Because they hate the monkeys.
Which is pretty fucked up.
Oh, the snake gen...
Is this up?
Is this the up part?
Or do we go follow the bones?
Oh, we follow the broke bones.
This is a giant ass snake.
It could be like a legless reptile.
A legless lizard.
Oh, it's him.
But bigger.
Oh, I think he found out about my London shanks.
I think he found out.
He's like, you've been shanking my kids.
Like, no, man.
Oh, no.
She found out.
She found...
How did I miss?
How do I always manage to miss?
I don't understand.
Okay.
Oh.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
He's killed.
The piggy is a distraction.
I can't see.
But nice.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Yeah.
That's right.
Use my spells early.
I'm getting as much damage as I can.
But I should...
Is he here forever?
Wait.
Is he going to fight for me forever?
He's great bait.
Like, aggro.
The fact that he can aggro him for me is really good.
All right.
No.
Okay.
Never mind.
He's not aggroing anymore because he fucking hates me, I guess.
All right.
No.
Okay.
Never mind.
All right.
I need to make sure not to...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Nice.
I had to make sure I don't accidentally...
I told you guys.
It's character development.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I'm chilled.
Chewbacca, help me.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Look at the way he fucking...
He fucking...
Wait.
He hurt me.
He hurt...
Oh, shit.
Oh my God.
They're listening.
He has access to my microphone.
Oh my God.
Wukong has access to my microphone.
He actually waddled over.
Okay.
I did not expect.
That's pretty good.
He's watching...
He's stream sniping.
They got the spyware.
Oh, my God.
Every copy of Wukong is personalised.
Alright.
Can't be a phase 2.
Oh, she just leaves.
She's like, you can take the children.
You can take the kids.
No, I wanted to read the lore!
Read.
Dwelling in a Buddha's form, when wings to ride the windstorm.
An iron heart through toils and spins.
A golden shell in splendour.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Nice, we did it!
You reading.
I'm a speed reader.
Did you guys know that?
How can a speed read?
I never said if I'm good at it though.
Hahaha!
Being able to speed read doesn't mean I'm good at speed reading.
It's just that, like, I can do it.
Oh?
What's he doing?
Oh no, is that his, like, wife?
His tears are of great use.
This is his answer.
Oh my god, wait, is that his wife?
Is that why he's crying?
His wife's dead.
Some kids say they were roommates.
Oh no, your very close roommate died.
His.
Hahaha.
Okay, let's see.
They never married, it's so weird.
Hahaha.
And they, like, shared one bedroom.
Like, I don't know, I was like, man, rent must be, like, really expensive, you know?
Hahaha.
They had to share one bedroom together.
My god.
What really good friends they were.
Turtle loot?
Yeah, I'm going back to the turtle loot.
Hahaha.
Yeah, I'm going to the tears.
I assume, whoops, that's not what I wanted to do.
Where did you cry, turtle man?
Wait, where did he cry?
There were...
Oh, it seems they were saving on...
They even, like, shared clothes sometimes.
My god.
Living in Canada must be really rough now.
Hahaha.
They shared a lot.
It was next to the stairs!
I don't know, I literally looked at the cutscene and, like, the cutscene was like...
Like, he was crying near...
How did your tears go this far?
How did...
His tears dropped into the sea.
Like, how am I supposed to fight his tears?
Hahaha.
Okay.
It's not...
I am...
Okay, now I'm...
Not only am I getting gaslit regarding studies.
I'm getting gaslit on where he fucking cried.
Like, they lied.
Where did you cry?
How am I supposed to fight tears and water?
Wouldn't that be, like...
Wouldn't that defeat the whole purpose?
Oh, there it is.
It's not even in the water.
Oh my god.
Alright, what is this?
Turtle tears.
Oh my god, I'm gonna fucking drink tur...
That's hardcore.
That's actually hardcore.
Alright, where's the turtle tears?
Oh, I have to do...
Oh, I have to do it in the...
Um...
That's...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I have to do it in the, uh, incense area.
I also have new items.
I don't even know which...
Oh, this one.
Okay.
Reduces...
Increases stamina recovery rate.
Uh, grants reduction when Gord is...
Okay, we already have that.
Increases...
In chilled state.
Moderately...
We don't need it.
We don't need chill resistance.
Bash my head against the wall until it works.
The Doki way.
Alright, now where do we go?
Where do we go now?
Do we go back to the tunnel?
Oh, further down?
Alright.
Chewbacca, you can deal with this.
Okay, you're not that...
You're not that important to me.
You're so not important that, like, I don't...
I missed.
But you're still not that important.
There's a boss near the turtle?
This way?
There's a...
There's a water boss?
West.
Which one's west?
Fuck, okay.
North is up.
South is down.
West is left.
West is left because I live in the west coast.
So, like...
Wait, is west left?
Are we on the left side?
Yes, we are.
We're on the left side.
That's...
That's how I do...
I know where west is because I'm on the west coast.
That's how I can...
Everybody knows I'm on the west coast.
I always say west coast, best coast.
Is that him?
Oh, wait, why is he using electricity and water?
Isn't that bad?
Are you friend?
Okay, he is not friend.
Oh, oh, I...
Okay, I have zero mana.
All right, this is a little awkward.
This is...
Zero mana.
Well, I did say I was gonna kill all the dragons in this world.
This is why we don't have dragons anymore.
In the modern world.
We kill them all.
Just like the dinosaurs.
You think humans didn't exist during the age of the dinosaurs?
That's what we told children.
To fool them.
To trick them.
But we existed during the prehistoric dino times too.
All right, nice.
All right.
The meteors.
The Illuminati.
Invented the whole meteor shit.
All right.
We got it.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, I have transform.
I have transform.
Forgot about transform.
Let's see.
All right, come on, this way.
What the fuck?
Let me kill you.
Illuminati summons the meteor.
No, it was Stanley Kubrick.
He did that as a favor.
After the moon...
After faking the moon landing, we drilled a hole in...
On the earth.
Oh my god.
A hole in the earth.
That is...
That...
Books about dinosaurs only existed during the 1960s.
Kubrick strikes again.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Nice, easy.
Why is this all coming together?
We agreed to let some...
Let him fake that.
Oh, he wants to be immortal?
What is he whining about?
He's already a dragon.
Maybe if you take off all your clothes, you wouldn't age that badly.
Are you doing phase two?
Oh, wait, no.
He's just...
He's just mad.
Did I beat up an old man?
Why do all the dragons not wear clothes except...
Oh, no, no.
We did fight some dragons with clothes.
I was gonna say, why do some dragons wear clothes and some do not?
Like...
Like that lady dragon didn't wear clothes.
We literally beat up an old man.
I'm sorry.
So sorry.
Hey.
Oh, the dog guy is here, too?
Oh, my God.
I'm so...
Now I feel bad.
Marina, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't speak Cantonese, so when you say his name fast, I just hear Chewbacca.
But it's not even right.
Oh, man.
I'm sorry.
You just...
I mean, like, you clearly hit me first.
I thought you were a friend.
I'm sorry, man.
You straight out... This was self-defense.
Like, yeah, I fucking punched the grandpa, but like...
Okay, if, like... Okay, if, like, some 80-year-old grandpa runs at you...
Like, about to hit you with his fist...
Like, you'd punch back, right?
Like, you'd fucking... You wouldn't let him just punch you.
You'd hit him back, right, guys?
Like, it may... Is that fucked up?
Is that...
Like, I don't want to get hit.
Like...
I don't want to initiate shit.
Literally, I was, like, friend, and then he tried to...
He tried to, like, electric shock me.
And then I had to teach an old man a lesson.
All I'm saying is that...
Self-defense, no matter what age.
I would... If a child runs at me trying to punch me, I will push him.
Because then... Because here's my reasoning.
Like, the child would think if I don't push him...
The child would think that, like, he has the right to, like, do whatever the fuck he wants.
And then he'll become, like, super spoiled.
He would become super spoiled if I don't push him.
I won't punch him.
Because, like, I have, like, a bit of morality.
But, like, I'll push him.
Like, I'll push him to the floor and be like, what the fuck are you doing?
Hey.
Boom.
Why can't he just do everything for me?
Oh, shit.
All right.
Like, I do have some...
Also, children are fucked because they don't have, like, any sense of, like, right and wrong.
So, like, I am here to teach him what is right and what is wrong.
Like...
I will...
I will take the hard...
I will take the hard job of teaching him what is right and what is wrong.
Exactly.
Hands rated E for everybody.
Oh, I don't have...
I don't have Healers.
It's okay.
He's not gonna do anything to me.
All right.
Last guy.
Get over here.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, I was actually...
What?
All right.
Nice.
Hello.
Oh, I don't know.
I'm just here for bananas.
Registered babysitter.
By the way.
Fuck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, treasure?
What is it?
Okay.
Thank you for spitting on my face.
Is this like a Finnish thing?
Okay.
Is this a Buddhist place?
I'm trying to listen to this man and buy his treasure.
A boar's alive.
Okay.
We have to figure out why there's fucking monsters everywhere in the Buddha realm.
Yeah, that's zhupaka.
He's so tiny.
I know.
I've never seen him this tiny before.
Is it because he's old?
Like, do they get smaller with age?
Like, he's like a little teapot.
Teapot pig.
Oh, I love it when like teapot pigs were a thing, but like And like people like because teapot pigs got super popular on social media and tik-tok So people were buying like those miniature it pigs and stuff But then like there were scammers out there that like just gave them regular baby pigs and then they grew up to be like those John ass like 200 pound pigs They're like I think my miniature pig is broken like HAHAHAHAHA They're like guys I thought this is supposed to be a miniature.
Yeah pigs grow up.
Just a normal pig
And they send them to the farm What's this?
Where are the fucking incense?
Oh am I medi- is this meditation?
Oh, no.
I'm just stealing.
Alright, I mean the same thing like Stealing is my meditation
Yeah, but warthogs are not that tiny too.
There's big-ass warthogs
There's loot for this area I'm looking
There's like so many like crevices and like areas that you're not even supposed to explore But like they're like bait areas to me
Okay, maybe this way can I go through here?
No, that's just aesthetic.
Oh God am I stuck?
No, no, please Please.
Because of exploration.
It just baits me on where loot should be.
Is there any more loot here?
I guess we go this way.
I didn't go this way yet.
Okay, we gotta kill this guy.
Charge it up!
There we go.
Just wanna make sure he's dead dead.
Alright, charge it up!
Okay, good.
He's getting involved.
Nice.
Oh shit, you're getting involved too!
Alright, nice.
Just wanna clear the path in case anything happens.
It's cause he's not actually...
Shroom Hong.
It's not actually him.
It's not him him, but I think it's him.
Like, so I think it's him.
Like, he's a clone or some shit.
But like... Oh my god, I have not been upgrading.
But he doesn't know it yet.
Uh...
Okay, I like the... You know what?
Yeah.
Uh... Oh, attack.
That's what I like to see.
I think it's him, but like, he doesn't know it yet.
Cause like, he's supposed to be the destined one.
So like...
And like, he already looks like...
And everybody was saying that he looks like him.
So I think he's like one of the clones or something.
Yeah.
I'm just thinking he's like one of the clones.
But it's not actually him him.
Cause we're like... The mission started being like, We gotta free him!
Oh, talk to beach dragon?
Talk to the grandpa?
Alright, I'm heading over.
Gramps!
Also like, I know I started this stream like...
Early, like at 12.30.
But I might not be... I might do not do a very long stream today.
Uh...
It's cause I have a lot of errands to run later.
Hello grandpa!
Oh, he says the same thing.
He says the same thing.
Liars!
I thought it would be something new.
Go back to the dog?
Where does he live?
Cause you can't just say go back to the dog.
I don't know where the dog lives!
We haven't even met him!
Oh!
I thought he traveled here!
You mean he didn't go to the mountains?
You have to go back to him?
Why can't he travel with me?
You know like the merchants?
That would travel with you always no matter where you go?
Like...
Why can't he come here?
Why do I have to go to him?
Alright, here we go.
Oh yeah, I forgot about Hong Kong Monkey.
He's been there for a while.
Okay.
Maximum health.
The older the one.
Okay, each sip requires three moderate increases.
I like the 40%.
That's because it's a bigger number.
When at full health, using the gourd recovers a moderate amount of mana.
Oh!
I feel like...
Okay, that doesn't matter because it's so rare to be full health.
Like whenever I'm fighting the bosses, I'm already going to be full health anyway.
So it doesn't really matter.
Is that you?
There you are.
That's you.
Oh, it gives three slots?
Oh!
Guys, I did tell you I'm a speed reader.
Not a very good one.
Alright, I'm ready.
Alright, here we go.
Brew.
What's this?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait, what did I use before?
Okay, the lora beats.
Oh!
That's so good.
Okay, nice.
I can read now.
Guys, I don't think I'm very good at speed reading.
But I'm not sure yet.
I need more data.
Am I supposed to buy something for him?
Am I supposed to...
talk?
Oh, there he is!
Sorry.
I'm still speed reading.
Oh, there he is.
He's still doing it.
I didn't know that.
Am I supposed to buy them?
Alright.
Alright, special made bone strengthening pellet.
Oh yeah.
I need to make my mind cores.
Celestial medicine.
Alright guys, I have nine!
Wait, no I don't, I have eleven.
Oh, I have more!
Alright guys, what did we get?
Okay.
Stamina, Recovery, Defense, Stamina, Mana, or Health?
HP, Health?
Okay, we'll do HP and...
Okay, that's two.
HP and Mana.
Okay, we'll do Mana first.
I'll do two Mana.
Oh god, where's the skip button?
Oh thank god, okay.
We'll do two?
And then...
What else should we do?
We still have... Oh, nice.
Alright, HP...
Stamina, Defense, or Recovery Rate?
HP and Defense?
Okay, we'll grab Defense then.
I'll do one Defense.
And then we'll do HP.
I'm mad at who needs HP.
I don't think this person played this game yet.
And then we'll put it on HP.
Okay, we're good.
Just dodge perfectly every time.
Just don't get hit.
Alright, time to talk to the Gramps.
Dragon Gramps.
Alright, Travel.
What?
Why do I have an opportunity to make medicine?
You know I'm not going to use it.
Alright, let's see.
There he is.
Alright.
We got you the medicine.
Your insurance kicked in.
Thank God.
Thank God, Grandpa Dragon.
Your insurance finally kicked in.
Alright.
Where is he?
Wait, where is he?
Why is he not in the water?
Oh, he's finally out of the water.
Are you done?
Are you done with your...
Are you done with your mid-life crisis?
Grandpa?
This is when I can finally make you extinct?
Look, I did say I was going to kill all the dragons.
I'm not making any exceptions.
Not even for you, Grandpa.
I mean at this point, like your time's come.
What?
He can nows just!
He just threw it away.
And now I have an innovative secret weapon.
The Punitive Realm?
Bro, you didn't even... what?
Where did he go?
Wait, what?
You didn't eat it.
So, the title is Clickbait.
I wanted to kill him!
Like, it's the thought that counts.
It's not like I didn't want to.
Alright, what's this?
New area?
A painted world.
Oh my god, it's like Chalk Zone.
No, it's not like Chalk Zone.
It's just a regular world.
There's a main hub?
What the fuck?
Where did I get here?
Oh, is this where everybody will hang out?
You want to come back here?
Why?
You don't like being in the fucking desert?
What's wrong with the desert?
Request medicine.
Oh, is he giving you free stuff?
Wait, is the Hong Kong monkey?
Are they all roommates?
They're sad and it gets everywhere.
Oh my god, please.
Why is it not just like matching E?
Oh my god, they're all roommates.
Oh, there he is!
Alright, what is this?
Oh, upgrade!
Nice.
Nice, we got the gourd.
Honestly, I just want to listen to English just for his British accent.
Hahaha!
Recovers a considerable amount of health for your nearby duplicates upon using the gourd.
Oh, but it only has like one slot, right?
Oh yeah, it does.
Okay.
Upgrade!
Okay, already upgraded.
Uh...
Hehehe.
Hehehehe.
Oh, you're friends with all of them?
Wait, you're all roommates?
How did you guys all meet?
How the fuck did you guys all meet?
Oh, I can like... wait, is this the...
This is the gourd update.
Guys, I can't because I need to save up for my weapon upgrade.
Like, I'm like 20,000 away.
I'm 20,000 away from the next update.
Apparently, I can grow plants now.
Oh, there you are!
Wait, you're all gods?
Oh, they're based on the Zodiac!
I know they said Zodiac...
Sorry, I...
But like, I didn't realize it was based on Zodiac after he said it.
But like, five seconds later.
Yeah, sure.
Just have all the seeds.
Can I just harvest them now?
Oh no, okay.
That's why there's...
Monkey, dragon, and dog.
Wait, will there be more deities?
Or is it just three guys?
What's this?
Wait, who's this guy?
But he's new.
Who's he?
I've never met him before.
The Prime Roommate.
Like, who is he?
Craft weapons?
Yeah, I can.
It's like halfway there for this one.
Wait, what's this?
66?
Nope.
Wait, he doesn't actually craft anything for me.
I'll challenge him soon, guys.
I'm just trying to figure out...
No, nothing...
I don't need to upgrade anything, technically.
Upgrade...
Oh!
I feel like I never have to upgrade my armor.
Because like, I always find better armor in the end.
Alright, challenge.
Yeah, but I'm a monkey.
Nice cat hurt monkeys.
Mommy and Daddy said my skin is bulletproof.
Wait.
That doesn't...
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, okay.
That's awkward.
Guys, I forgot.
Bullets doesn't mean knife.
That may be bulletproof.
But I still have to deal with knife.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, what is this?
Holy sh...
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm gonna turn now.
I'm dropping hella frames right now.
It's a visual...
Okay, let's put that on low.
Let's put that on...
That's way too many effects.
Alright, we're fine.
Oh my God.
It's so much better.
No, I gotta lie.
I can just get willpower from that.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
What?
Did I die?
I died?
That was such a...
That was so strong.
What's the...
Oh, it's my zoom in.
Because we can't make the subtitles bigger.
Okay.
Now that I understand your combos.
I wasn't sword proof, guys.
Okay.
That's why they...
That's why they made sure nobody has a gun in this world.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Wait.
When did I mute myself?
When did I mute...
I was so locked.
I was muted the whole fight.
I'm sorry.
I was shit talking.
I'm...
I'm talking bad shit just to be muted.
Why did I mute myself?
Okay, now I'm actually locked in.
Oh, nevermind, like I said that and I fucking missed.
Now I'm actually locked in.
Alright.
Dog.
Oh, how do I dog?
Okay, now that I know mini monkeys are bullshit, we will not do that again.
What?
I thought I...
Okay, I'm not locked in.
JK.
Does it look like I'm not locked in?
Because I'm not.
Jesus.
What does he even...
Are you fucking... Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Where did he go?
Are you... Oh my god.
I hate his teleporting abilities!
Oh my god.
No!
He sent me away from it!
Oh my god.
He's not messing around.
Okay, now I'm actually locked in.
Now that I know his movesets, I'm actually locked in.
For real.
Is he even like giving me good shit?
Wait, what do you mean second phase?
There's no way.
An honorable tiger would not trick me with a second phase.
Alright.
No last.
Only gaming.
Like right starting now.
Boom!
Wait, did I do it?
Oh no.
Please.
Boom.
Okay, nice.
Lock in.
That's not fair!
I dodged it!
What?!
Okay, that was such a dodge!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Come on!
What?!
Okay.
Alright, I have not downloaded it.
Guys.
I might have lied a little bit.
I have not downloaded it.
Just a little.
Oh my god.
This guy hits so hard.
Why does he hit so hard?
Alright.
Did I get command grabs?
No.
No!
His command grabs is bullshit!
Are you fucking...
How does he still have new moves?
How does he still...
I don't understand.
How does he...
How does he still don't understand your moveset?
Oh my god.
Oh, please leave me alone!
Please!
Oh!
Oh, that was a sick-ass dodge though.
That was me gaming after, like, fucking it up.
I finally game.
Okay, there.
Tiniest poke of my life.
No, don't, please, please.
Please.
Jesus.
Why is he so difficult?
Maybe I should upgrade.
Maybe I should upgrade before I try again.
Okay, this time.
I'm focused.
I'm so focused.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, no!
Not nice!
Focus, focus, focus, focus.
Focus, Doki.
You have to focus.
You can't let him win!
You killed all the other Tigers!
You killed Frank the Tank!
And Tony the Tiger!
And then his dad!
You can't kill this Tiger, too!
No, Tiger will be safe.
Nice.
What?!
Still?!
How does that hit me?!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, God.
Ho, ho, ho, ho!
That shit's scary!
Okay.
God damn it!
He's a cloud!
Oh!
What?!
He broke it?!
Okay.
That's not fair.
That's actually not fair.
Okay.
I can't believe he broke it!
Okay, I'm just gonna leave when he does that.
That shit fucking sucks.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Okay, I got a smack.
I got a smack in.
That's all that matters.
All right.
I downloaded it.
Oh!
It's not fair!
The frame dropped!
Fuck me up there!
Oh, my God.
He actually won because my frames dropped!
That's so bullshit!
My frames dropped and he won!
It was the ping!
It was actually the ping.
He commands the ping.
That's not fair.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Broke.
He's...
He doesn't want me to have a good day.
Like, fuck her in particular.
Why did I fucking move away?
Bro, I even moved away!
And then he was like, and then he sucked me back into the hell.
Oh, my God.
I hate this guy so much.
I, like, don't know what stance to use, too.
I haven't had a chance to really use my stance.
Am I too underleveled?
Why is he so difficult?
Oh, my God!
I got salty.
I had to keep beating all the hard boxes so quickly.
I'm enjoying this.
Tommy, I hope you fucking take, like, five hours.
Hello?
I don't know what happened!
What the fuck?
I...
Oh, my God.
That's crazy.
Okay, like, that's actually so freaky.
That's so freaky.
Like, I've never had that happen to me.
I've had so many issues, but, like, but, like, but, like, literally, all three monitors just turned off.
And, like, my PC was still on, but, like, it restarted itself.
There was not even a blue screen.
Like, all three monitors just went black.
That was so weird.
It was the curse of Tommy.
Like, was it a power surge?
Like, what the fuck happened?
It was so weird.
And, literally, oh, my God.
Like, there was no blue screen, too.
There was no blue screen.
It just, everything just turned off.
That was, I've never had that happen to me before.
So, like, I was like, what the fuck?
I've had so many PC issues, but I never had a moment where, like, um...
Is it because this area is, like, kicking... Maybe this area is so PC intensive that, like, my PC was... No, I didn't lose power anyway.
It was literally this.
It was just my PC.
It literally just...
Everything, like, all...
Like, my three monitors, black screen.
And I was like, what?
Like, it was so weird.
Oh, my God.
No, do I have to do the upgrades again?
Do I have to... No, okay.
I don't.
Oh, thank God.
I was just saying, please don't make me do the upgrades again.
Please don't make me.
Like, oh, but something's weird.
Oh, my God.
What happened?
What am I... Oh.
Wait, what?
What happened?
Why did everything just suddenly... No, wait.
My CPU and GPU are fine.
What's going on?
What's going...
What happened?
Actually, what happened?
Everything...
What the fuck?
What happened?
Okay, give me a second.
That's so weird.
Me...
I don't know what happened.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It's every...
The moment I cursed Tommy out.
I got hit with karma.
It's not fair.
Why does this happen to me?
Why do I get karma?
He started it.
Tommy, I...
This was self-defense.
This was self-def...
Why?
This was literally self-defense.
I was defending myself.
Every time I can't even fucking defend myself.
I can't even...
I can't even defend myself.
It's so fucked.
Alright.
I'm gonna reboot.
I'm gonna reboot Wukong.
Why does this happen to me?
Tommy has blood.
You have my blessing.
Don't give me a commuter.
Rest in peace.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I rebooted Wukong.
Maybe that will fix it.
It was self-defense, your honor.
I swear.
It was self-defense.
He shot the first bullet.
Am I not allowed to defend myself after that?
Alright.
Let's see.
It's this area.
It's this fucking area.
I'll come back to the tiger later.
Exactly!
In my defense, Tommy started it.
Oh my god.
What happened?
Alright, we're coming back to the tiger another time.
I can't.
Okay.
What happened?
Okay, everything's fine for now.
Okay, graphics.
Okay.
We'll go back to hide because we're leaving this area.
Oh my god, what happened?
What happened?
How did everything go so wrong?
How did my PC restart and then everything went wrong?
How did this happen?
I don't understand.
I literally...
Oh my god.
This is Tommy's fault.
This is fucking Tommy's fault.
You pissed on the wrong Tommy.
I believe Tommy.
Everything was fine until Tommy cursed me.
No, there's no way this is the resolution.
It can't be the resolution.
Alright.
Crap, it's 120.
Okay, maybe that's it.
Oh my god.
Tommy, this is your fault.
Note to self, do not piss off Tommy.
Do not piss off Tommy.
How could this happen to me?
I didn't make any... I didn't make that many mistakes.
Oh my god.
I hear you.
Me oopsie daisies.
The client pleads.
Tommy started it first.
We're not sorry.
I refuse to apologize to Tommy.
I refuse to apologize for Tommy.
Okay, temperature is too high.
Whoa.
Hahaha.
It might be that.
It really might be that.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Things will be...
Things will be okay.
You had to...
He deserted!
Hahaha.
What did you do, Tommy?
What did you do to my PC?
Hahaha.
I was fine before God.
Everything was fine.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
To be fair, it was half a compliment because I said these would be all the hard losses easily.
Tommy... Oh my god.
Look at what you did!
Now he's angry!
Hahaha.
Now he's here to beat you up, Tommy.
That's right.
My muscle is here to beat you up, Tommy.
Hahaha.
That's fucking right.
Who the fuck am I?
Hahaha.
Let's fight a boss.
What's this?
Who are these guys?
Oh, it's okay now.
Oh, thank God.
Everything is okay now.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
We're not going...
We're gonna fight the tiger another time.
I think...
I think the tiger...
The effects and quality...
The tiger was so HD...
My PC had to restart itself to protect himself.
It has to be the hub.
There's something wrong with the hub.
There's something wrong.
Hahaha.
I'm gonna find where Tommy lives.
But like, as a joke.
Hahaha.
It's meditation time.
I'm enhancing the location right now.
Hahaha.
Talk Tommy.
It's too late hearing Doc's first name.
Hahaha.
There can't be that many Tommies in the world.
Alright, let's see.
What's that?
Alright, nice.
We have the enhanced tiger subdued.
Oh wait, does this subdue that tiger?
That's right.
That's right, Tommy.
Shouldn't have fucking called your...
Shouldn't have fucking called yourself Tommy.
That's on you for...
Hahaha.
For making your first name your username.
Who said Tommy?
Who the fuck would call themselves...
Okay, why would you call yourself Tommy on the internet?
That is like...
Like, why would you...
I've always wanted to be a Tommy.
call yourself Tommy on the internet?
You can call yourself anything...
and you pick Tommy.
Like...
Yeah, officially she defeated...
Tommy Pickles.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Where the fuck do we go?
Guys, I don't think I'm finishing chapter 3, guys.
Oh my god.
Because I don't think we're finishing chapter 3 today.
Hahaha.
Power Rangers.
He's just a big fan of Rugrats.
No key.
Okay.
Look, even dad's...
gonna beat you up, Tommy.
Hahaha.
Leave Tommy alone.
Can't believe it.
Streamer bullies...
all Tommies.
You're the...
strongest Tommy.
He's Tommy Prime.
Alright, nice.
Spirit I won't use.
Is the lag...
gone now?
I can't tell.
Because I have to look at my game.
Wait, oh.
That's right.
Tommie.
If you can't beat me...
I may as well...
take a bite out of the wound.
I want to see...
the last two games of Tommie.
All Tommies?
Yes.
It's more fun to be a Tommie than to be Tommie...
and play Tommie.
Yeah, he only has one master.
Seems like a little shit.
Is he like a good Buddha?
Or like...
The Buddhas that are like pricks in the Journey to the West.
Like the ones that really hate Shim Hong.
Does he actually like me or not hate me?
We don't know.
He looks not evil.
Yeah, but that's how they get you.
That's how some of the Buddhas get you.
We don't know.
Because some Buddhas are assholes in the Journey to the West story.
Because they really hate him.
To be fair, it could be self-defense for the Buddhas.
Because he is an asshole.
Like, Shim Hong is an asshole.
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
Wukong is sort of asking for it.
Because he's like...
You know, he tried to kill them.
He's like, I hate the gods.
And then he tried to kill them.
Alright, let's see.
Never reaching heaven with that mindset.
I mean, Wukong, all he wanted to do was take over the heavens.
Yeah, they're like super petty.
Alright.
We consume.
Consume.
The heavens kind of suck.
I don't blame him.
Hahaha.
God.
This area is so huge.
Oh my god.
Why did I fucking stumble?
Yes, pig!
Spit on him!
That's what they want!
What's this?
Where am I?
I'm in a perpetual state of like...
Hahaha.
Let's see.
Get out of here.
Now where am I?
Oh, there's another Buddha.
Another Buddha statue.
I have to find all the statues?
Yeah, but like...
He has the ears.
So shouldn't we listen to him?
I didn't find all the statues.
All four of them.
That's right.
What are you gonna do?
You're blind.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Oh.
That's what he's gonna do.
Poke!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Yes, heal me.
Spit it on...
Hahaha.
I shouldn't encourage that.
I think he likes it.
Hahaha.
I don't think he knew...
I don't think he even realizes he has healing properties.
We just discovered it.
Later on.
All right.
That's right.
Don't worry.
I got you, Chewbacca.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I remember that story.
I remember that.
The hand story.
A lot of people did adaptations on that particular one.
Because everyone was like, Lil can't even leave his hot hand.
Oh, shit.
Please.
Please leave me alone.
I just want to kill you.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Not nice.
Poke!
All right.
Nice.
That should be it.
All right.
Buddha time.
Where is the master?
Is he dead?
I don't know.
But is he dead?
Why is it just you?
Where's there the rest of our gang?
Where's the other guy?
I don't remember the other guy's name because he's not as important to me.
I always only remember the master, Chewbacca, and Shingpong.
I don't remember the fourth guy.
I never remember his name.
He's just there.
The fourth guy?
He's just there for me.
I'm sorry.
I never remember his name.
The other guy.
Oh, you mean the horse doki.
That's so fucked.
The horse.
There's also the horse.
There's a fourth guy.
Yes, there's a fourth guy.
But no one remembers his name.
I don't remember his name.
The fuck is the fourth...
Oh, there it is.
Is it that Buddha?
Did I bow to that one already?
The dragon horse.
Guys, there's a fourth one.
Did I already bow to this one?
Yeah, I must have, right?
Yeah, I have.
Where the fuck is the fourth Buddha statue?
Where the fuck
is the fourth Buddha statue?
On the path?
Did I actually miss one?
God damn it.
Okay.
I definitely am like...
I don't know what happened.
That PC restart really fucked up my...
The PC's not having a good time.
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
Tommy, it's Tommy.
Oh.
Yeah, what's that sound?
It's something to do with the game.
Because the game is...
The game, for some reason, is like, I'm gonna make sure you have the worst time of your life.
Like, I don't understand.
Like, what happened?
How did I suddenly...
How did I suddenly start lagging out of my...
How did I start lagging?
It doesn't make any sense.
Okay.
I will never apologize to Tommy.
He did this.
He caused this.
Alright, here we go.
I did it.
I talked to all four statues.
What?
Yeah, where's the path?
...
No!
I didn't do that!
Now we're gonna be cursed!
...
You never hit the Buddha!
We had an entire fucking book about the punishments!
We had an entire book where we got punished for trying to hit the Buddha!
Have you not learned?
Oh no, he's gone.
He forgot.
Let's see.
He's gotta take the lock.
Wait, which one was the door that opened?
Was it this?
No.
What's the pathway?
It's like the pathway has opened.
Which one?
Is it this?
Does this just go up?
Alright, what if I turn everything low?
Something happened when the PC restarted.
Something.
What the fuck happened?
Tommy, what did you do?
What did you do?
Tommy already cursed you.
Buddha curses nothing.
Something happened.
And I'll never know what he did to my PC.
Something happened in the span of...
In the short time frame.
Alright.
Just...
No!
I will never apologize!
It was not my fault!
If Wukong never apologized, I'll never apologize!
Alright,
let's see.
Look, if Wukong can become a Buddha after everything he's done...
Like, I'm saying.
Oh, it's Sandy!
Okay, that's the guy.
I'm gonna forget his name again.
Go in.
Everything Wukong has done and he was able to be a Buddha?
I mean...
Look, he...
He had a lot of people to apologize for.
And if he only apologized to one person after everything he's done...
All I'm saying is that, like...
Might as well just be no apologies.
Might as well.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm sorry.
I know it was a super short stream, guys.
I know it was a super short stream, but we're gonna call it here.
We...
We're having some...
Some technical difficulties.
I'm up...
I'm up my flow.
I'm off my flow.
Okay.
I'm sorry we couldn't...
I...
I think, like...
I honestly think the...
That hub...
I think the...
Uh...
The hub, like, fucked it up.
Like, my PC...
Like, overheated in the hub.
Because...
There was so much stuff there.
Like...
So...
So we're gonna call it here and let my PC rest.
Yeah, I think my PC has to rest right now.
Anyway, guys.
Um...
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get a move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
We gotta let PC rest after everything today.
It's...
It's not doing so well.
Yeah.
I, like...
I was, like, so...
I was, like, I fixed it!
And then...
And...
The curse...
The curse of Tommy has hit us.
The curse of Tommy.
Anyway, I'll see you guys next time.
Bye-bye.
Bye.